yu
[Musique]
tha
thor
quote
le rhône en avant
peuple libyen
[Musique]
tu attends
disney présente vaiana la légende du
bout du monde
le film phénomène qui a conquis petits
et grands à voir et à revoir encore
encore et encore
vaiana la légende du bout du monde avec
vous partout en blu ray 3d blu ray dvd
vidéo à la demande et achats d'élite al
quatre bonnes raisons de passer à
l'achat digital grâce à la chaîne tiji
talent pas besoin d'être un sorcier pour
regarder vos films sans connexion
internet sur tous vos écrans
et vous serez les premiers à les
découvrir après leur sortie en salles
enfin vous pourrez les emporter partout
avec vous même au bout du monde
retenez bien ces quatre bonnes raisons
et tenter de gagner une croisière en
souliers en jouant sur six plaies vous
aussi
répondez à l'appel de l'océan avec
vaiana la légende du bout du monde
le film évènement disponible en achat de
gide halles à partir du 30 mars disney
présente vaiana la légende du bout du
monde
en fait disponible en achat digital
redécouvrez la plus extraordinaire des
aventures familiales la relâche et
végétales
regardez là encore et encore sur votre
tv tablettes ou smartphones
trop facile vaiana la légende du bout du
monde
disponible en achat digital le 30 mars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]